[Music]
william is in riverside california hi
william welcome to the ramsey show
hey dave hey ken what's going on ken
finishing up the proximity principle and
looking forward to your new book so
congrats on that thank you um
yeah okay so here's my situation um i'm
active duty navy and about to be moving
at least three times in 2022 my wife is
about to graduate from her master's
program in occupational therapy and
she's going to be getting her
credentials to practice in the first
half of the new year we are on baby step
two on our second to last debt which
should be paid in the next two months
and that would just leave us with eighty
thousand dollars in student loan debt
we're looking forward to making our
shovel bigger with my wife being able to
work in the field but we've been talking
a lot about when we will start having
kids and we're concerned about balancing
the debt snowball and starting our
family so i'd love to sell advice and
comfort in this situation
uh we don't we don't decide about kids
and marriages based on debt
when it's time to have babies you have
babies you'll work it out
you'll work it out you got plenty of
room they're not that expensive they uh
they don't eat that much
uh all this crap the kids will i mean if
you have 17 kids it'll break you that's
different but if you're gonna have a
baby you're gonna be just fine you're
gonna be just fine and the same thing
with marriage the only thing we tell
folks about marriage is you need to be
on the same page
that you're heading in the right
direction to gather but i don't tell
people not to marry someone with that
and i don't tell people to not have
babies because i got debt
as a matter of fact quite the opposite
it's a good reason to have babies what's
the timeline look like
forget that for just a moment to
uh start trying to have babies with your
wife moving into a new career have you
talked about that
a little bit you know we kind of go back
and forth because she does have a little
bit of shame and you know the fact that
most of the student loans that is hers
and i've you know i feel great that's
not a big deal um but
i guess somewhere between when we're
moving next year we'd like to at least
start we're going to be coming off of
birth control soon and
um we're just kind of looking forward to
maybe mid 2022. but yes i think it's a
shame that's getting us
i know yeah there's no shame yeah
no babies are god's gift
babies are the best thing ever happened
to me yeah
and she's she's going to pay that off
she's going to make very good money as
an occupational therapist you guys are
on the path you know how to pay this off
you're going to get there have the
babies and you're going to get through
the baby steps all right let's go ahead
and say
she's probably an occupational therapist
for a while yeah because you got to
clean this mess up that's exactly right
so it's not like she's going to be a
stay-at-home mom
uh you don't have the you don't have the
budget for that but it's not that you
can't have kids for sure so you do what
you want to do it sounds like you
already are
i miss the part where i like i'm going
to say no when they're going to go back
on birth control that's that's really
awkward as crud
but uh no i'm definitely not going there
so um i i can't even believe i said that
out loud but anyway that's what he said
it's what he said so it's a little warm
in the studio all of a sudden for me i
don't know about anybody else
no they'll get it i mean you know look
she's she can be a working mom and crush
this thing and that's beautiful